- It's time for
tonight's #HashtagWars.
(audience cheering)
Amazon Japan is
selling a cookbook
of some questionable
culinary delights.
Condom dishes I want
to make for you.
This book of 11 recipes
includes condom fruit parfaits,
condom escargot and butter,
and some has swallowed on
the way back from Amsterdam.
So, in honor of their
culinary ingenuity,
tonight's hashtag is #DongFoods.
(audience cheering)
We are really mature.
But examples of this would be
scroatmeal, shaft
sackaroni and cheese,
or cup-o-balls.
I wanna put 60 seconds
on the clock, and go.
Julien,
- Reese's Penis Butter Cups.
- Yes, points.
Nikki,
Boneme.
- Yes, points.
Michael,
- Penis ala vodka.
- Yes, points.
Julien.
- The Whopper.
- Yep.
Hope so.
Yeah, points.
Nikki,
- Six and a half
inch sub, toasted.
- Okay, good, points.
Julien,
- Full Monty Christo.
- Yes, perfect, po6ints.
Michael,
- Apple pie ala chode.
- Yeah, points.
Oww, god damnit.
Nikki,
- Stuffed dick in breast.
- Yes, points.
Julien,
- A turdicken.
- Yeah, turdicken, points.
Wait a minute, that also
had turd in it, nevermind.
Nikki,
- In and Out, and In and Out.
- Yes, points.
- Neverending breaddicks.
(buzzer buzzing)
(audience cheering)
There are breaddicks.
The next time I go to a
restaurant that serves those,
I'm just gonna
push my head down.
- [Nikki] Take it all.
- Thanks for the bread.